Bryce is, like, when we're having technical meetings, Bryce often dials in from his kitchen while making bread and other, like, things. It's amazing. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 32, recorded on June 5th, 2021. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we finish up our four-part conversation with Chandler Carruth and Patricia Oz. In this episode, we talk about how to hire inclusively, company culture, and much more. If you haven't listened to the first three parts of this episode, they'll be linked in
布莱斯这个人，怎么说呢，我们在开技术会议时，布莱斯经常一边做面包和干别的什么，一边从厨房拨入电话。这太神奇了。欢迎来到《ADSP播客》第32期，录制于2021年6月5日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，完成了我们与钱德勒·卡鲁思和帕特里夏·奥兹的四部分对话的收官篇。在本期节目中，我们探讨了如何进行包容性招聘、公司文化以及更多内容。如果你还没有听过本期节目前三部分，链接会在
the show notes. We highly recommend you do that first, as this is the final chapter of this four part miniseries. Okay, okay. Since I'm doing this next week, all of my interviews are next week. So I wanted to touch on one of your points. You have one that says build an actually inclusive culture, but I'll put that aside because I'm right now in hiring. So you hire inclusively. What does that mean? For me, hiring inclusively means causing the outcome of your hiring process to be an inclusive culture, right? And so it's the first thing to understand is that like, I'm a little bit outcome oriented. And so I would like the actual experience of the hiring process to also be inclusive. That's not my top goal. That's a fairly brief period of time. I want the team that I'm building, right? The organization that I'm
节目shownote中给出。我们强烈建议你先去听前三部分，因为这是这个四部分迷你系列的最后一章。好吧，好吧。既然我下周要进行这方面的面试，我所有的面试都在下周。所以我很想谈谈你的一个观点。你其中一条提到要建立一个真正包容的文化，但我先把这个放一边，因为我目前正在进行招聘。那么你如何进行包容性招聘呢？对，这意味着什么？对我来说，包容性招聘意味着让你的招聘流程产生一个包容性文化的结果，对吧？所以首先要明白的是，我是有点结果导向的。因此，我希望招聘流程的实际体验也是包容的。但这并不是我的首要目标。那只是一段相当短的时间。我想要的是我正在建立的团队，对吧？我正在建立的
building, the company, whatever it is, I want that to be inclusive for the next, you know, years, right? And so what I'm aiming at here is, like, how can I structure the hiring process and every aspect of it to ensure that the resulting team is going to kind of sustain inclusivity and actually be kind of an inclusive and welcoming culture and environment for the long term. So some specific things that I like to do here. The number one thing that I actually like to do is kind of fun. It's a bit recursive. It's like to actually talk about inclusivity and hiring for inclusivity in the hiring process.
组织，公司，无论是什么，我希望在未来几年里，它对每个人都是包容的，对吧？所以我的目标是，如何构建招聘流程及其各个方面，以确保最终的团队能够某种程度上维持包容性，并在长期内真正成为一种包容和欢迎的文化与环境。所以这里有一些我喜欢做的具体事情。我实际上最喜欢做的第一件事其实挺有趣的。它有点递归。那就是在招聘过程中实际讨论包容性和为包容性而招聘。
This has a bunch of really great effects. So if you study psychology, there's this great psychology study done on what changes people's behavior. And so they ran an experiment where people at a national park in the u.s were going in and stealing uh um petrified wood out of this natural park and it's natural resource right like this takes i don't know so however many thousands of years maybe it's millions i've i'm not a science person clearly uh but like like this basically this petrified wood is this very rare resource there's a natural park that has a bunch of it and people walk on trails the way they're supposed to but then they would see something and they just go off the trail
这会带来一系列非常棒的效果。如果你研究过心理学，有一个非常棒的心理学研究，研究的是什么改变了人们的行为。他们做了一个实验，在美国的一个国家公园里，人们走进去，从这个国家公园里偷走……呃，那些硅化木，也就是天然资源，对吧？这需要，我不知道……不管多少千年，也许是几百万年，我显然不是个搞科学的人……但是，基本上这种硅化木是非常稀有的资源，有一个国家公园里有很多这种东西，人们按规定在小径上走，但接着他们看到某些东西，就会离开小径，
and grab themselves a little souvenir take it back so they wanted to stop this because it's like it's finite um and it's it's depleting this like particular natural resource people should come to the park and see it not take it with them so they tried different techniques of how do you get people to change their behavior? So the first thing they did was they put up a sign. It said, like, don't steal the petrified wood. This is a natural resource, important to preserve. There's, like, all the really good reasons why you shouldn't do this thing.
然后给自己抓一小块纪念品带走。所以他们想阻止这种行为，因为这东西是有限的，呃，而且正在消耗这种特殊的自然资源，人们来到公园应该去欣赏它，而不是把它带走。所以他们尝试了不同的技术，来看看如何让人改变行为？所以他们做的第一件事是竖起一块牌子。上面写着，比如，不要偷硅化木。这是一种自然资源，对保护很重要。上面列出了所有你绝对不应该做这件事的很好理由。
They tracked the occurrence of theft. It skyrocketed. Because, like, if other people are are stealing it that must be a good thing to stamp precisely it turns out what they did was advertise that taking this stuff was a common occurrence and people responded by matching that perceived norm and so in psychology, this is the perceived norm within a group, almost exclusively dictates how people behave in that group. And so they then put a different sign up on the park, which thanked all of the visitors for preserving these petrified wood and not taking it, and how appreciative they were, and how much they have because people don't take this
他们追踪了盗窃事件的发生率。结果飙升了。因为，如果其他人都在偷，那这一定是一件可以做的好事，确切地说。事实证明，他们所做的事情实际上是在宣传拿走这些东西是很常见的现象，而人们的反应则是迎合这种感知到的规范。所以在心理学中，群体内部感知到的规范几乎完全决定了该群体中人们的行为。因此，他们在公园里竖起了另一块不同的牌子，感谢所有游客保护这些硅化木并没有拿走它们，表达了他们的赞赏，并且因为人们没有拿走，所以他们留下了多少……
plummeted. All of the theft plummeted, right? And so this tells us how to influence a group of people. You don't tell them, well, you better not be a jerk if you come to work on my team. That isn't going to work. That's going to advertise to them, wow, you must have a bunch of jerks on your team if you have to warn off every person you hire about being a jerk. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. You want to set the expectation that it is normal, right? That it is just the way things happen on the team, that people act inclusively, that they intentionally think about inclusivity, plan for it, and kind of incorporate into everything they do step one talk to them about how you hire people who are inclusive right because now you've you've just you've just advertised wow the person
所有的盗窃行为都暴跌了。所有的盗窃行为都暴跌了，对吧？所以这告诉我们如何影响一群人。你不能告诉他们，好吧，如果你来我的团队工作，你最好不要当个混蛋。那可不管用。那等于是在向他们宣传，哇，如果你不得不警告你雇用的每个人别当混蛋，那你的团队里一定有一堆混蛋。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。你要树立这样一种期望，即这是正常的，对吧？这就是团队中事情发生的方式，人们的行为是包容的，他们是有意地考虑包容性，为此做计划，并将其融入他们所做的每一件事中。第一步：跟他们谈谈你是如何招聘那些具有包容性的人的，对吧？因为现在你刚刚……你刚刚宣传了，哇，那个负责招聘的人关心包容性，我想整个团队也一定如此，对吧？所以他们进来了，他们的行为就像……你知道的，我想融入其中。我想表现得像这群人中的正常人一样。所以我会那样做。在面试过程中谈论心理安全感。你就会促使你招聘的人去维护团队中的心理安全感。所以这是第一件事，实际上就是敞开讨论。这也是件好事，因为这意味着你进行包容性招聘的策略同时也是透明招聘，对吧？
doing the hiring cares about inclusivity well i guess this whole team must right and so they come in and their behavior is like i you know, I want to fit in. I want to behave in the way that is normal in this group of people. So I'm going to behave that way. Talk about psychological safety in your interview process. And you'll cause the person you hire to preserve psychological safety on the team. And so this is the first thing is actually just open up the discussion. And this is also great because it means your strategy to inclusive hire is also transparent hiring, right?
你把你团队中已经拥有的文化全部告诉那些你正试图招聘的人。通过这样做，你促使那种文化得以存在。好的。这真的是超级超级有趣。我下周就会用这个。我的意思是，另一个非常有趣的部分是，你还会得到一个极好的自我选择偏见。是的。对吧？
You just tell the people you're trying to hire all about the culture that you already have on your team. And by doing so, you cause that culture to exist. Okay. And this is super super fun. I will use this next week. I mean, the other really fun part about this is you also get a beautiful self-selection bias. Yeah. Right?
如果你在招聘过程中谈论包容性，并且说得非常清楚，这有多么重要，它对于整个团队文化有多么基础，以及每个人是如何真正优先考虑它的，那么那些对参与这种群体或坚持这种行为规范不感兴趣的人就不会接受这份工作。是的，这就是你的目标，对吧？我一直在纳闷，但我一直在想怎么说才好。比如，我怎么……我……我怎么把这个呈现出来？这一直是个问题。比如，我……我一直在想，我开玩笑地跟……跟……前几天跟我谈过的一个人说。就像，我不能走进去说，就像，你可能会工作，你知道的，你可能会和一个同性恋者一起工作，或者一个跨性别者，或者，你知道的，你知道的，一个女人，或者，你知道的，一个年轻人，或者一个跨性别者，或者你知道的，呃，你知道的，一个女人，或者，你知道的，一个年轻人，或者一个老年人，或者你知道的，你怎么能……像，我不能……我……我不能这么说，那会……所以我不……我不太同意，我其实觉得你可以这么说。所以，我有一个我很喜欢问的具体的、实质性的问题……
If you talk in your hiring process about inclusivity and you make it super clear how important this is and how fundamental it is to having the whole the whole team's culture and how everyone really prioritizes it people who are not interested in participating in that kind of a group or adhering to that norm of behavior will not take the job yeah and that was your goal right i've been wondering but i've been wondering how to say that, though. Like, how do I, how, what, how do I present that? And that's been an issue. Like, I, I, I, I, I've been thinking, like, I've been, I joked with, with, with someone I talked to the other day. It's like, I can't go in and say, it was like, you might work, you know, you might work next to a gay person or a trans person or, you know, you know, a woman or, you know, a young person or a trans person or you know uh you know a woman or you know a young person or an old person or you know how are you like i can't i i can't say that it did it be it so i don't i don't quite agree i actually think you can say that so i like as a concrete question that i love to ask
人们为了进行包容性招聘，对吧？比如，我们来谈谈……我们来谈谈团队动态。比如，想象一下你来到团队中，你在开一个团队会议，然后，你知道的，你的一个同事被误性别了（misgendered），哦，让我解释一下什么是误性别，好吗？所以对于跨性别群体来说，如果有人用了错误的代词，对吧，这可能会非常非常令人沮丧，因为这个人已经在与他们的性别认同作斗争了。这是一个非常敏感的话题，而且这是一个错误。对吧。所以这对于那个人来说是一种复合因素。
people like in order to hire inclusively right like? Like let's talk about, let's talk about team dynamics. It's like, so imagine you come onto the team and you're in a team meeting and, you know, one of your colleagues gets misgendered and, oh, let me explain what misgendering means, right? So for the trans community, if someone uses the wrong pronouns, right, it can be really, really frustrating because the person is already struggling with their gender identity. This is a very sensitive topic and it's a mistake. Right. And so it's kind of this compounding factor for that.
好的，现在想象一下，你在一个团队会议中，有人误性别了你的一个同事，而你意识到了这一点。你会做些什么？这里是最棒的部分。就算他们没有给出一个好答案也没关系，这里的秘密在于，这并不是关于……并且，如果有人是……如果你在面试，而有人问你这些包容性问题，而你说，哦天哪，我没想过这个，我不确定该怎么做，那也没关系，对吧？实际的问题是，你将如何对这个假设情况作出反应，即使你没有一个好的回应，即你有一个跨性别同事……你现在有了一个跨性别同事，你已经把这个摆上台面了……这就是事情所在，你最好做好准备。所以自我选择就开始了，然后你也会看到，对吧？
OK, so now imagine you're in a team meeting and someone misgenders one of your colleagues and you realize this. What things would you do? And here's the best part. It doesn't matter if they have a good answer the secret here is that it's not about like and it's fine if someone is if you're interviewed and someone asks you one of these inclusivity questions and you're like oh my gosh i haven't thought about that i'm not sure what to do that's fine right the actual question is how are you going to respond to the hypothetical even if you don't have a good response that you have a trans colleague right you have a trans colleague now you've you surfaced this is this is the thing you better be prepared for and so the self-selection starts right and then you also get to see right
就像，你想知道你应该怎么做，还是不想知道？或者你对提出这个话题感到沮丧，对吧？这些正是你实际上在寻找的区别。所以，这也是一个求职者很容易通过的面试题，他们不需要……并没有一个所谓的“正确做法”意义上的正确答案。正确的答案是，你知道的，不要心烦意乱，不要害怕这个，对吧？要有关怀。而且我认为这是面试别人的绝佳方式。我……我……它要被写进书里了。需要明确的是，虽然可能没有标准答案，但对这个问题绝对有错误答案。有很多……但我认为，但我觉得……
like are you do you want to know what you should do or do you not or are you frustrated that this has even been brought up right these are the kinds of distinctions you're actually looking for and so so it's also an easy interview question for people to pass they don't need there isn't a right answer in the sense of like the right thing to do the right answer is to you know not be upset to not like fear this right to have any caring and and i think this is a great way to interview folks i i i will it's it's going in the book it should be clear too although there may not be a right answer there is definitely wrong answers to that question there are lots of but i think that but i
我认为这在两个方面都是一件好事，就像，你知道的，噢不，如果有人回答说：“我真的认为这不应该是我们工作中关心的问题。”好吧，那你现在得到了一个非常明确的信号，知道该走向何方了，然后你知道，那个人在这个公司里不会开心的。所以我们分道扬镳对双方都更好。因为，你知道，那不是……而这些正是我最喜欢的那些问题，它们有着极高的信噪比，对吧？并且还能准确地传达出这个人即将面对的是什么。因为这意味着，对你——面试官来说，它们不仅有极高的信噪比。
think that's a good thing both ways like you know oh no if someone responds by saying i really don't think that should be an issue that we care about in our work like you okay well you've now got a very clear signal on on where to go and i then that you know that person will not be happy in in in this company so so it's better for both of us that we part ways. Because, you know, that's not... And these are the questions I like the most, are the ones that have just tremendous signal-to-noise ratios, right? And also kind of telegraph exactly what the person is coming into. Because it means that they're not just good signal-to-noise ratio for you, the interviewer.
对求职者来说，它们也同样具有极高的信噪比。我真的很喜欢这样。因为这正是我一直在挣扎的事情。比如，我该如何发出这个信号？同时，我也想确保某个新来的人可能在某种程度上还在柜子里（未出柜），或者可能是跨性别者，但我看不出来，你知道的，为了让他们意识到……
They're also good signal-to-noise for the interviewee. I really like that. Because this is something I've been struggling with. Like, how do I signal this? And also, I want to make sure that somebody coming in that might be in the closet in some way or might be trans, but I can't tell, you know, for them to realize that
这是没问题的。而且，你知道的，他们会是安全的，他们可以做他们想成为的人。但我必须以某种方式发出这个信号。而且，发出这个信号，我……是的，这对我来说本周将是一个挑战。我的意思是，我真的很喜欢用于包容性招聘的另一件事是——我以前觉得这是一件非常傻的事情，而我现在完全成了它的信徒——那就是拥有一个团队文化文档，实际上就是让你的团队写下他们的文化是什么。所以我在谷歌的团队就有一个团队文化文档。
that's okay. And, you know, and that, that they'll be safe and they can be who they want to be. But I have to signal that in some way. And, and, and doing that signaling, I, I, yeah, it's going to be a challenge this week for me. I mean, another thing that I really like for hiring inclusively is, so I used to think this was a really silly thing, and I'm now a total convert to it, is to have a team culture document, to actually just have your team write down what their culture is. So my team at Google has a team culture document.
它是庞大的。我的意思是，我们说的是好几页好几页又好几页。重点并不是每个人都会把它们全部读完。他们会阅读他们关心的那些部分，诸如此类。但这里另一个非常好的地方是，一旦你把它写下来了，就直接把它分享给候选人。很多人会觉得，哦，但这合适吗？我说，为什么不呢？就直接说：“我们刚刚花时间写下了我们认为的团队文化是什么。”
It's massive. I mean, we're talking like pages and pages and pages. And the point isn't that everyone's going to read all of it. They're going to read the pieces of it that they care about, that kind of thing. But the other really nice thing here is just once you have this written down, just share it with candidates directly. And a lot of people are like, oh, but is that appropriate? I'm like, why not? Just be like, we just took the time to write down what we think the culture of our team is.
很高兴与你分享。如果你对此有疑问，请告诉我。它超级长。不要觉得你需要全部读完。没有小测验。你会把它发在面试中吗？是的。哦，好的，当然。或者只是给一个链接并说，你知道的，如果你感兴趣，随时可以看一看，如果你有问题，随时可以在面试中提问，对吧？你有现成的例子吗？我很想……我只是在想，我很想为我的团队做一个这样的东西。你知道外面有什么现成的例子吗？我本来想说奈飞（Netflix）。
Happy to share it with you. If you have questions about it, let me know. It's super long. Don't feel like you need to read all of it. There's no quiz. Do you send it in the interview yeah okay sure or just give a link to it and be like you know if you're interested feel free to take a look if you have questions feel free to ask them in the interview do you right do you have an example one that i'd like i i'm just thinking like i'd love to make one of those for my team do you know of any example ones that are out there i was gonna say netflix
呃，他们写过……他们整本书都写进去了，书名叫《无规则规则》（No Rules Rules），这简直是一整本书。我不想读一本书。而且我不确定这是否……这不是一个好……我不想说它不是一个……这是一种不同的文化，我们这么说吧。他们试图在书中传达这样一点，即这不是一家适合所有人的公司。如果它是适合你的公司，你会爱死这里的。但它是一种非常非常不同的文化。值得赞赏的是，他们对此非常坦诚。比如，他们在书中直言不讳地指出，你知道的，有时我们会得到不好的媒体评价，但我们的公司并不是为了成为适合所有人的公司而设计的。它是为特定的一群人设计的。我们在寻找那些人。不管怎样，但这可能不是一个好的例子。不，但我认为这是一个好例子，因为它是一个好例子，因为它完全是……
uh they wrote they had a whole book written uh called no rules rules which is literally a whole book i don't want to read a book also i'm not sure that's that's that's it's it's it's not a great well i don't want to say it's not a it's a different culture let's say that and they they try to make that point across in the book that like it's not not a company for everyone. If it's the company for you, you'll love it here. But it's a, it's a very, very different culture. And to their credit, like they're very upfront about that. Like, they're, they say like straight up in the book, like, you know, sometimes we get bad press, but our company is not designed to be like the company for everyone. It's designed to be the company for a certain set of people. And we're searching for those people. Anyways, but yeah, that's probably not a good example. No, but I think it is a good example because it's a good example because it's a totally
一种不同的文化。所以他们在宣传他们的文化。他们在解释他们的文化是什么。他们允许人们自我选择加入或自我选择退出。即使那可能与我想要打造的文化有所不同，那么看看他们是如何做到的，我认为这可能会很有用。比如，我该如何沟通……我们做过的事情之一，以及我们花了这么长时间才进行招聘的原因——我们原本计划今年招聘。从一月份开始这就是计划。
different culture. And so they are advertising their culture. They're explaining what the culture is. They're allowing people to self-select into that or self-select out of that and even if that is a different culture than maybe the culture that i'm i i want to make then then looking at how they do that i think it could be useful and like how can i communicate like one of the things that we did and the reason why we waited so long to to do the hiring we were planning to hire this year. And that was the plan from January.
但我们花了一整段时间在官网上制作了一个网页，叫做“工作”（Working）。它基本上解释了我们作为一个公司是谁，我们的结构如何，所有的工作相关内容。它甚至包括薪酬，这样你可以弄清楚我会得到多少薪水，它还有你的养老金和一切，比如病假，你知道的，育儿假，各种各样的事情——很多很多东西。我们把它写了下来，然后把它放进了广告里，这样……其想法是，人们可以通读这些内容，然后弄清楚这是否适合自己，然后再选择是否申请。
But what we spent the whole time is making a webpage on a website, which is called Working. And it basically explains who we are as a company, how we're structured, all of the work stuff. It even has the pay so you can figure out like what will i be paying and and it has like your pension and everything like what like sick pay like you know parental leave all sorts of like like lots of stuff and we wrote it down and then we put it in the ad so that And the idea was that then people could read through that and they could figure out, is this for me or not? And then choose to apply or not.
但这只是广告中的一个链接。广告超级短，因为基本上就是：你会写代码并且可能对安全感兴趣，基本上就是这样。这就是为我们工作的感受。呃……但我认为我可以……我想我们可以做更多类似文化的东西。但后来我想，也许我想和这些新来的家伙一起创造这个，当他们出现的时候。因为目前我们太小了，我认为我们需要更多的人来……我确信你有一个想法……和团队一起建立文化是个好主意，但我确信你对某些原则以及你想要看到的事情的基础有一些想法。有什么要补充的吗？
But it's just the link from the ad. The ad is super short because it's basically like, do you code and could be interested in security, basically. And here's what it's like to work for us uh but but i think i could i think we could make like more a culture thing but but then i think maybe i want to make that with these new people when they show up because currently we're so small i think we need more people to i'm sure you have an idea like building a culture with a team is a great idea but I'm sure you have an idea of some of the the principles and like the foundation of things that you want to see in
但它只是广告里的链接。广告超级短，基本上就是：你写代码吗？对安全感兴趣吗？这就是在我们这里工作的体验。呃，不过我觉得我们可以把它做得更偏向企业文化一些，但后来我又觉得，也许我想和那些新来的员工一起做这件事，因为目前我们团队太小了，我觉得我们需要更多的人来——我确信你懂我的意思，和团队一起建立企业文化是个好主意，但我确信你对想要看到的某些原则和基础事物也有自己的想法。
that team that you're building right but I it becomes very dominated by me I think that can be okay though and here's here's also the a different. So what we do is we have the stock, right? And so I wrote one of them. I wrote kind of the first version. It was based on one that a colleague that some of you may know, Titus, wrote one for his team. And I kind of looked at that and took some ideas from this and synthesized one. And actually our larger org has adopted it. I'm hoping that I'll actually be able to share this document at some point,
你正在建立的那个团队，对吧？但我感觉它很容易被我个人主导。我觉得这其实也没问题，不过这里还有另一种不同的情况。我们是怎么做的呢？我们有一个存量文件，对吧？其中一份是我写的。我写了可以说是第一个版本。它是基于我的一位同事写的版本改编的，有些人可能认识他，叫Titus，他为他的团队写过一个。我看了那个版本，从中借鉴了一些想法，然后综合出了一个。实际上，我们更大的组织已经采用了它。我希望我以后能在某个时候分享这份文档，
but I need to figure out how I get the okay to just publish this because I just want to publish our team. Even if you don't publish it publicly, could I get it? Well, maybe by the fourth episode of this mini-series with Chandler and Patricia, we can link it in the show notes, maybe. Check the show notes. If it's there, Chandler got the okay. Or just the index. I don't know just the index you know just the the the other though the interesting thing about how how we do this to kind of keep it from
但我需要弄清楚如何获得批准来发布它，因为我只想发布我们团队的。即使你不公开它，我能拿到吗？好吧，也许到了钱德勒和帕特里夏这个迷你系列的第四集，我们可以在节目简介里放个链接。去看看节目简介吧。如果在那里，说明钱德勒搞定批准了。或者只放目录。我不知道，就放目录，你知道的。不过，关于我们如何做到这一点，还有另一个有趣的地方，那就是为了防止它
becoming kind of unexclu because you also don't want this to be exclusive right like oh well but are you allowed to like participate in and so every time someone joins the team you don't just share the team culture document with them you also share you'd say and please contribute anything that's missing or or suggest changes that this is it's got to be a living document and you just have to anchor people in like this is a living document it is never meant to stay static and so as new people as you hire people right you can write the first version and that's fine but as you hire people you say like when you join the team you're going to get to you know put your fingers your fingerprints on this you're going to get to put your impression on
变得排外，因为你也不希望这东西太排他，对吧？比如，噢，好吧，那你有没有资格参与进来呢？所以，每当有人加入团队时，你不仅要和他们分享团队文化文档，还要分享并对他们说：请补充任何缺失的内容，或者提出修改建议。这必须是一份活的文件，你必须让大家明白：这是一份活的文件，它绝不是一成不变的。因此，随着新人加入，随着你招募新人，你可以写出第一个版本，这没问题；但当你招募新人时，你会对他们说：当你加入团队时，你将有机会在上面留下你的印记，你将有机会把你的影响力注入
it if there's stuff that you think should be in the culture document that isn't or things that are in it that you don't think makes sense okay and then it just keeps evolving right yeah okay so then i could write like a first draft and then it could be something that grows over time but go back to the sign right you want to set expectations and you want to establish the norms um because otherwise it can be really really hard something that i've watched a lot of organizations struggle with um is this actually gets into you know some of the other things right like how do you resolve misaligned incentives between organizations one of the things that i watch organization after organization struggle
其中。如果你觉得文化文档中应该有某些内容却没有，或者里面有些内容你觉得说不通，都可以提出来。然后它就会不断演变，对吧？是的，好吧，那我就可以先写一个初稿，然后它可以随着时间不断发展。但回到标志的问题上来，对吧？你想要设定期望，你想要确立规范，因为否则的话，事情可能会变得非常非常困难。我看到过很多组织都在为此挣扎，这其实涉及到其他一些事情，比如：你如何解决组织之间不一致的激励机制？我看到一个又一个组织在挣扎的其中一件事，就是
with is when the organization came into existence without this clear and established set of norms especially around things like inclusivity. Changing the culture afterward is, in my opinion, the hardest thing to do for organizations. It's so hard that I have almost no examples of it being done successfully. The psychology study that I'm mentioning is also cited by Harvard Business Review and some other groups. And the thing they talk about is like, well, okay, so if you run an organization and you want to change its culture, how do you do that? There are already norms, right? They already exist.
当组织成立时，没有这样一个清晰且既定的规范体系，尤其是在包容性等方面。事后改变文化，在我看来是组织最难做的事情。它难到我几乎找不到一个成功完成的例子。我提到的心理学研究也被《哈佛商业评论》和其他一些机构引用过。他们谈论的核心是：好吧，如果你运营一个组织，你想要改变它的文化，你该怎么做？规范已经存在了，对吧？它们已经在那儿了。
And about the only way that anyone succeeded at doing this is you basically have to have an incredibly persuasive group of leaders that everyone in the organization will really look up to and admire and within that small group all of you have to unanimously decide to go and project a new norm into the group and if you basically get a single leader that's not engaged and not trying it this whole thing fails because you can't overcome the existing norms so this is this is sort of related to your previous thing of of like this this group mentality and and the leader and and losing or winning and projecting uh enthusiasm versus and how it it kind of goes through the entire group and they kind of all get pulled into it.
几乎唯一能让人成功做到这一点的方法是：你基本上必须拥有一群极具说服力的领导者，组织中的每个人都真的很崇拜他们、敬佩他们；在这个小群体内部，你们所有人必须一致决定去向群体投射一种新的规范。如果你基本上只有一个领导者没有参与、没有尝试，那么整件事情就会失败，因为你无法克服现有的规范。所以，这其实和你们之前提到的那种群体心态、领导者、输赢，以及投射热情的方式有点关系，看它如何贯穿整个群体，然后大家都被卷入其中。
Okay. So, yeah. The easy way is to just – and, like, there's the great comic about inclusivity. It's, like, you know, all of the – what is it? Red-colored fingers say, oh, you look different. We don't want you here. And they're, like, fine. And the green-colored one's, like, fine.
好的。所以，是的。简单的方法就是——就像关于包容性的那个精彩漫画一样。大意是，你知道，所有的——怎么说来着？红手指的人说：噢，你看起来跟我们不一样，我们不希望你在这里。然后他们说：好吧，绿手指的人说：好吧，
We'll go make our own space over here. Right. But there is a trick here. Right. So one thing that you can actually do is you can use this psychological factor against people because the easiest way is if you create a new space and you put a sign at the door that says, by the way, everyone in this space likes to do X, then everyone who walks through the door sees that sign is like, oh, I guess here we're going to do X, right? We're going to be inclusive, right? And so this moving into a new space is one of the easiest ways to do this. And so now you can see how you can align the psychological incentive with what the organization wants to do. So one of the best tactics for changing culture is to cause people to feel like they have changed where they are right feel like there is some movement that they're coming to a new thing there is actually
那我们去那边建立我们自己的空间。对。但这里有个小技巧。所以，你实际上可以利用的一个方法是，你可以利用这种心理因素来对付人们，因为最简单的方法是：如果你创造了一个新空间，并在门上挂一个牌子，上面写着“顺便说一句，这个空间里的每个人都喜欢做X”，那么每一个走过这扇门并看到那个牌子的人都会想：“噢，我猜在这里我们要行事X，对吧？我们要做到包容，对吧？”因此，搬进一个新空间是实现这一点的最简单方法之一。现在你可以看到，如何将心理激励与组织想要做的事情结合起来。所以，改变文化最好的策略之一，就是让人们觉得他们所处的环境变了，
one i think really good example of a company that did reinvent itself and uh change its culture and that company is microsoft under yeah under satya nandela. And there's a whole book written on it called Hit Refresh. And it basically has like a couple chapters where it talks about how when Satya was like tapped on the shoulder for the role of CEO, he knew that like this kind of reset and exactly what Chandler was saying, like where they put this sign. And you know, we used to be a company that innovated. And that was like the pioneer of the technology industry. And if you, you know, if you've been paying attention to the tech world, like the reputation that Microsoft had a decade ago versus now where they're building out VS Code, which
我觉得微软就是一个很好的例子，它重塑了自我，改变了文化。这家公司就是在萨蒂亚·纳德拉领导下的微软。有一整本书写了这件事，叫做《刷新》（Hit Refresh）。书中花了好几个章节谈到，当萨蒂亚被委以重任担任CEO时，他知道需要进行这种重置，这恰恰符合钱德勒刚才所说的——他们把牌子挂在哪里。你知道的，我们曾是一家充满创新精神的公司，曾是科技行业的先驱。如果你一直关注科技界，微软在十年前的声誉，与现在他们打造出VS Code的声誉截然不同，VS Code
has become one of the most popular editors in the world. And it supported Linux first before it supported Windows. Like that would have been like unheard of. And like everyone was scared when they bought GitHub and it's, it's just been nothing but like good things. And so yeah, it is very rare that it happens, but there are some good examples of like, you know, maybe less than I can count on one hand that I know of. The way he framed it though was essential. It was about a new Microsoft, not just a new culture. It was a new Microsoft. They were going to change where they were so that people would actually change their behavior when they moved into
已经成为世界上最受欢迎的编辑器之一。而且它对Linux的支持甚至早于对Windows的支持。这在以前是闻所未闻的。每个人在他们收购GitHub时都感到害怕，但结果带来的全都是好消息。所以，是的，这种情况发生得非常罕见，但我知道的一些好例子，两只手可能都数得过来。不过，他构建这个概念的方式至关重要。这关乎一个全新的微软，而不仅仅是一种新文化。这是一个崭新的微软。他们要改变他们所在的地方，好让人们在搬进
the new space. This is so much easier than trying to get people to change their behavior without a new space. It's sort of like a branding process, a rebranding process. hopefully hopefully i won't have to do that i mean but it's for me this is this is kind of a a fun thing because you can you get this this whole tactic works even if you tell people what you're doing like you don't have to be sneaky there's no need to like mislead anyone you can go up to a group of people and say we need to change our culture in order to do that i'm going to we're going to create this artificial construct of a new version of our team and we're all going to move over to this new version of our team
这个新空间时，真的会改变他们的行为。这比试图在没有新空间的情况下让人改变行为要容易得多。这有点像一个品牌重塑的过程。希望，希望我不用去做那件事。我的意思是，但对我和来说，这其实是一件挺有趣的事，因为你可以发现——整个策略甚至在你告诉人们你在做什么时依然奏效。你不必鬼鬼祟祟的，完全没必要误导任何人。你可以走到一群人面前说：“我们需要改变文化，为了做到这一点，我要——我们要为我们团队创造一个新版本的虚拟构想，然后我们都要搬到这个新版本的团队里去。”
like you've just given it all away, right? It still works. It still is effective because it's just about, like, it's just about having kind of a reason for people to internalize the change, right? It's about framing. It's not about it being like the secret thing. If people can think about this as, oh, I'm moving into the new Microsoft. I already work at Microsoft, but I'm going to be in the new Microsoft. Then they're going to internalize the need to change their norms and change their behaviors. Whereas if instead they think of this as, oh, I'm bad and need to change. As opposed to something I can do versus something that i'm just being chastised for and you get this defensive thing it's like no my culture isn't bad i don't need
就像你已经把底牌全盘托出了一样，对吧？它依然奏效。它依然有效，因为这只关乎于——只关乎于给人们一个内部化这种改变的理由，对吧？这关乎于构建框架，而不是把它当成什么秘密行动。如果人们能把这看作是：“噢，我要搬进崭新的微软了。我已经效力于微软，但我要身处一个崭新的微软之中。”那么他们就会将改变规范和改变行为的需求内化。而如果他们把这看作是：“噢，我很糟糕，我需要改变”，这与“我可以做某事”相比，而不是“我只是在被训斥”，你就会产生防御心理。你会觉得：“不，我的文化不坏，我不需要
to change my culture why would i change my culture how dare you tell me that i have a bad culture like no i i'm gonna stick with this right i i like this and it's just an amazing difference i i i can't apply it next week but this i can apply like in my, you know, in my life. And it ties back to what Bryce was saying, too, about like it's inspiring people that like this is something like when you read if you read Hit Refresh, which is the book that like documents it, like people were like they were so excited like when satya got up on stage and was talking about this like new microsoft like people there have been people that have been working at microsoft back when it used to have that reputation of like it was it was this pioneer of the industry and and now here was someone that was full circle saying let's get back to that like we're gonna it's gonna take time it's gonna be hard but we can and like it i'm sure the book is biased to a certain extent they want to tell tell a good story, but it, uh, from reading it, I was like, oh man, this is like,
改变我的文化，你凭什么说我的文化不好？不，我要坚持这样，对吧？我喜欢这样。”这种差异简直太惊人了。我下周可能用不上，但在我的生活中我可以应用它。这又回到了布莱斯之前所说的，关于激励人们去关注这一点——当你阅读《刷新》（记录这一过程的书）时，人们是多么兴奋。当萨蒂亚走上舞台谈论这个崭新的微软时，有些员工从微软还拥有“行业先驱”声誉的那个年代起就在那里工作了，现在却有一个人重新回归初心，说：“让我们回到过去那样，我们要——这需要时间，会很艰难，但我们能做到。”虽然书的内容在某种程度上可能带有偏见，他们想讲一个好故事，但从读这本书的感受来看，我当时就想：天哪，这简直是……
you could feel the excitement coming off the pages. No, I have to read it now. I am also, I also wrote down the no rules rules also. Yeah. Hit refresh is definitely a better, uh, it's a more, it's a more exciting read. No rules rules is it's a very like chapter like chapter three, onto this part of the culture, chapter four. It's an interesting read. Do you have like any book from NVIDIA, like an NVIDIA culture? I don't, not that I know of.
你能从字里行间感受到那种兴奋之情。不，我现在必须去读读它了。我也把《无规则的规则》（No Rules Rules）记下来了。是的，《刷新》绝对是一本更好的、读起来更令人兴奋的书。《无规则的规则》非常像——第三章讲文化的这部分，第四章讲那部分，读起来挺有意思的。你们有没有关于NVIDIA的书，比如NVIDIA文化的书？我不知道有这样的书。
We've got GPU gems, like one, two, and three. There are some like internal documents in a few places that talk about it. But NVIDIA is also a smaller, like an order of magnitude smaller than Microsoft and it doesn't have as specialized, I'm going to say, culture as Netflix. And so I think because of that, there has not been a desire or a need to write something quite as extensive. NVIDIA's culture is very interesting because NVIDIA
我们有《GPU Gems》第一、二、三卷。有些地方有一些内部文档谈到过它。但NVIDIA的规模也更小，比微软小一个数量级，而且它没有Netflix那样独特的文化，我想正因为如此，大家一直没有愿望或需要去写一本那么详尽的东西。NVIDIA的文化非常有趣，因为NVIDIA
has, it doesn't have a lot of established hierarchy, which is really, it's something I absolutely love about the company. It's one of the reasons why I is really, it's something I absolutely love about the company. It's one of the reasons why I'm there. I was going to say, it's great for Bryce. You know, when I started at NVIDIA, I was hired to work on one thing. And when they started, they told me there's no product manager for this thing. So you'll sort of have to do that. And at some point I just sort of decided one day, like, all right, you know, like I'm not, I'm going to just decide that I want to expand the scope of what I'm doing. So I'm just going to start calling myself. I'm just going to
没有很多既定的层级结构，这真的很棒，这也是我极其喜欢这家公司的原因。这也是我为什么在那里的原因之一。我本来想说，这对布莱斯来说太棒了。你知道，我刚进NVIDIA时，招我进来是让我负责一件事。他们刚开始时告诉我，这件事没有产品经理，所以你得自己兼顾着做。在某个时候，我有一天突然决定：“好吧，你知道吗，我不——我决定扩大我所做事情的范围。所以我开始称自己为……我开始
start saying that I am the C++ core compute libraries team. And like nobody, nobody stopped me from doing that. I just, I synthesized the team. This is what Chandler is saying here. You are, you are making the room and you are naming the room and you are saying, right, if you want to be in this team, then you should move into this room with me. Yeah. And the great thing about NVIDIA is that NVIDIA is a place where nobody's going to go and tell you you can't do that because you didn't go and do it the proper way. You might, you know, of course, it's not a place where there's no rules. You know, if there's something that you can't do for a good reason, you'll get told that. But you're not going to get blocked solely on process and progress. And so you can, in many ways, you can shape your own destiny at NVIDIA, which is really appealing to me. But on the other hand, you know, for some people, they really like having
说我是C++核心计算库团队的。”结果没有人阻止我这么做。我自己捏合了这个团队。这就是钱德勒刚才所说的：你在创造这个房间，你在为这个房间命名，你在说：对，如果你想加入这个团队，那你就应该跟我一起搬进这个房间。是的。NVIDIA最棒的地方在于，它是一个没有人会跑来对你说“你不能这么做，因为你没有按正规流程来”的地方。当然，这并不是一个完全没有规则的地方，如果你因为某些充分的理由而不能做某事，你会听到反对意见。但你不会仅仅因为流程和进度而被卡住。所以在很多方面，你可以在NVIDIA塑造你自己的命运，这对我来说真的非常有吸引力。但另一方面，你知道，对某些人来说，他们真的很喜欢
a clearly established hierarchy and like, you know, sort of knowing how things work, you know, what they should be doing, et cetera. And so for that sort of person, it might be, you know, the NVIDIA lack of structure might be scary. It might be intimidating. Yeah. I only have like a baby example for that. But I remember at Opera in the beginning, it went of Agile and all of that. We introduced Agile and we basically did all the things. We read the books and then we did all the things and we read the books and then we did all the things um and one of the things that I found interesting was that some of us who were very self-driven
有清晰确定的层级结构，喜欢知道事情是如何运作的、他们应该做什么等等。对于那种人来说，NVIDIA缺乏结构可能会让人感到害怕，甚至令人生畏。是的。我对此只有一个微不足道的小例子。我记得在Opera刚开始搞敏捷开发（Agile）以及诸如此类的事情时，我们引入了敏捷，基本上把书上写的所有套路都做了一遍，我们读了书，然后照着做了所有事情，我们读了书，然后照着做了所有事情。我发现有趣的一点是，我们当中有些自我驱动力很强的人，
and didn't really need much structure and and we we planned our days and we knew what we were going to do and we found it to be overhead mostly it's just okay yeah we can do all of these things but we still know what we need to do so we just need to do those things but some people they absolutely loved it they felt like they finally had some structure and something you know and a list and and for them this was like an amazing experience and i found it very interesting how we could come at the same culture because this was also a culture change and and get totally different experiences so i i agree with you that some people they don't like working like that oh wow oh look at that is this sharing properly so we we probably have to start wrapping up soon but this this might be a great way to wrap up is that there's this meme that I,
其实并不太需要太多结构，我们自己规划每天的时间，知道自己要做什么，所以我们觉得这主要是额外的工作负担。好吧，我们可以做所有这些事情，但我们本来就知道自己需要做什么，所以直接去做那些事就行了。但有些人却绝对喜欢它，他们觉得终于有了一些结构，有了一些条理，有了一个清单。对他们来说，这是一种奇妙的体验。我发现这很有趣：我们如何走向同一种文化——这也是一次文化变革——却获得了完全不同的体验。所以我同意你的看法，有些人就是不喜欢那样工作。噢，哇！噢，看那个，这样分享合适吗？我们大概得开始准备收尾了。这或许是个很好的收尾方式：有一个模因（meme），
someone shared with me when I was at Amazon of the different corporate structures across. What are the six companies? Amazon, Google, Facebook, Microsoft, Apple,
我还在亚马逊时有人分享给过我，讲的是各大公司的不同公司结构。那六家公司是什么？亚马逊、谷歌、Facebook、微软、苹果、
Oracle. The Microsoft. Yeah, it's pretty good. Yeah. The different, the different the different warring organizations i think nvidia's would look the most like facebook's where it's just like a disorganized
甲骨文（Oracle）。微软。对，挺形象的。这些不同的、互相征战的组织。我觉得NVIDIA的结构看起来最像Facebook的，就是一个杂乱无章的、
uh a disorganized collection of of nodes that are connected with no no real clear hierarchy i i think that would work for me actually i. I think that kind of that i do for me to know what i'm expecting the folks on my team to be and it's not even that it's really for me to know what they are doing right now but i sort of like you know if it if it works for them they want to use that as the way to track great if they want to do if they want to use something else that's great it's it's but like it's there for me to keep an eye on things, not for me to impose anything upon them. But I think that's a good idea. Because that gives the possibility of having different kinds of people.
由各个节点组成的杂乱无章的集合，彼此连接，没有什么真正清晰的层级。我觉得这其实很适合我。我觉得这样做……我需要知道我对团队成员的期望是什么，甚至不是为了了解他们现在在做什么，而是如果这行得通，如果他们想用这种方式来追踪，那就太棒了；如果他们想用别的方法，那也行。但这只是为了让我能关注进展，而不是为了把什么强加给他们。但我认为这是个好主意，因为这让吸纳不同类型的人才成为可能。
Yeah. I think we have a tendency to want everyone to be the same so they fit into the same system. And if you can have people being able to control their day more themselves and the people need more structure, have more structure and the people who. Yeah, I guess I'm lucky in that the sort of role that I'm in and the sort of team that I'm building, it's primarily senior engineers are doing the sort of work that we're doing. Um, uh, there aren't, it's not, it's not the sort of work where you would staff it up with a large number of junior engineers. Um, uh, and because of that, um, I don't really have to deal with overseeing more junior engineers in that, um, you know, that means that the folks that I'm working with are people who are mostly self-sufficient. They're mostly people that I just sort of got to point them in the right direction. And I'm very blessed in that regard that they're all fairly senior and self-sufficient.
是的。我觉得我们有一种倾向，总想让所有人都千篇一律，好让他们塞进同一个系统里。如果你能让人们更多地掌控自己的日程，让需要更多结构的人拥有更多结构，让那些……是的，我想我很幸运，我目前所处的角色以及我正在建立的团队，成员主要都是资深工程师，他们做的是我们这类工作。这不是那种需要配备大量初级工程师的工作。正因如此，我不需要去监督更多的初级工程师，这意味着与我合作的人大多能够自给自足。他们基本上都是我只需指明正确方向就能自己干的人。在这方面我非常幸运，他们都相当资深且能够自给自足。
Yeah, no, right now we're hiring seniors, but definitely in the future, that's something that's going to be a whole other thing. Like how to take in juniors and and and help them evolve and and develop and that's but we're not doing that this time so i'm just gonna push that problem to some other time we we can come back on and have another three hour podcast in uh whenever whenever that happens like two years. Two years. All right. We probably should start to wrap up. But yeah, thank you so much for taking all this time. You've literally given us so much gold content.
是啊，不，现在我们正在招聘高级人才，但未来肯定会考虑另一回事，比如如何招收初级员工并帮助他们成长和发展，但这次我们不这么做，所以我只是把这个问题推迟到以后。我们可以在大约两年后的某个时候再来做一个三个小时的播客。两年。好的。我们大概应该开始收尾了。不过，非常感谢你抽出这么多时间。你简直给我们提供了太多宝贵的干货。
Maybe we'll do two Papa John's episodes. We don't know. Thanks for listening. We really hope you enjoyed this four-part miniseries. And once again, thank you to Chandler and Patricia for spending so much time with us. Have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也许我们会做两个棒约翰的节目。我们不知道。感谢收听。我们真心希望你喜欢这个四部分的迷你系列节目。再次感谢钱德勒和帕特里夏花这么多时间陪我们。祝你今天过得愉快。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。